welcome today on AI adventures we're
joined in the studio by Justin Zhou a
Google research engineer hey Justin all
right thanks for joining in the studio
today yeah it's great to be here we're
gonna be talking today about natural
language interfaces and how computers
and humans can talk to each other in
ways that are natural and not awkward
yep sounds good
awesome so I want to start by talking a
little bit about your team's
area of research and kind of the general
natural language processing field and
then we'll delve into your area of
research and see where our conversation
takes us yeah that sounds great
so broadly speaking the area of my
research is natural language processing
or NLP and what that is NLP is all about
trying to understand how humans
communicate with each other and how to
get a computer to kind of replicate that
behavior so that we can interact with
computers in a more natural manner wow
you guys really picked a small field to
target yeah I know if he sounds super
broad yeah it's like everything yeah
it's pretty broad um so in fact like I
have some slides that we can pull yeah
that'd be great yeah yeah so first I
think it's important to talk about the
conversational user interface and for
something like the Google assistant
there's two big domains of NLP problems
that come into play on one side you have
the problem of understanding which is
what did the users say what was the
user's intent and on the other side you
have the problem of generation which was
what should we say to the user and how
do we respond in a way that's
intelligent and conversational right so
I work on the generation side and the
ultimate goal of natural language
generation is to teach computers to turn
some kind of structured data into
natural language which we can use to
respond to the user in a conversation
wonderful and this is definitely
something that I feel like
conventionally NLP has really been
broadly thought about as a field where
it's all about processing the words and
understanding what text means but you
are working on the generation side which
in a lot of ways often gets overlooked
and so it's really great that you're
able to kind of tell us more about this
side of things yeah mmm that's what I'm
here for
so how do you then teach a computer to
generate natural language rather than
just understand it right so for now
let's set aside the structured data you
know part of natural language generation
and we can focus on the natural part of
the natural language generation so what
makes a conversation like the one we're
having no human
speaking of the one we're having it's a
little meta that we're having a
conversation about what makes something
conversational
so that's a common remark on our team
yeah we have to not be too robotic in
our conversation yeah so I think this
breaks down into two kinds of
requirements first of all the content of
what we have to say it has to make sense
in the context of the conversation so is
what I'm saying
an appropriate response to what you're
saying does or is it out of the blue hey
what are you having for dinner so that's
kind of out of the loop that's kind of
out of the blue yeah definitely
so yeah exactly and then I have to think
about if what I'm gonna say is actually
gonna answer your question so if you
were gonna ask me where we want to go
for dinner it would be weird to just to
suggest like a coffee shop or a clothing
store right yeah yeah unless you really
wanted to get some coffee stains on your
clothes for dinner yeah I guess the
second requirement is that you accept to
use the language correctly so this is
like you know how's my grandma do my
verbs agree or you know if I'm using a
pronoun is it ambiguous that makes sense
so it's basically what do you say and
then how do you say it exactly okay yeah
and you also mentioned earlier there's
this structured data that we kind of put
aside where does that come into play
that's a great question so structured
data primarily helps us figure out the
first requirement which is what we want
to say for example if let's say a user
asked us about the weather next week in
Santa Clara in Google search results we
see a box filled with all this
information about the weather for the
next week okay and some are within this
data hopefully answers the users
question and we just have to figure out
how to
all this data into a response to the
user that's kind of the problem that
we're focusing on in natural language
generation and that's because we're
talking about a situation where we're
going to say our answers not just show
them the box to look at that's correct
it's like an audio interface in that
case I guess I can imagine a sort of
naive solution for this sort of problem
we already have the data right yeah so
but I don't know if it would be
sufficient well you know that's depends
by all means go for it right so let's
say we make some kind of a template
right and we can say you know on blank
day it'll be blank temperature and then
some blank weather condition like on
Tuesday it'll be 72 degrees and partly
cloudy and then you could build a full
forecast by just iterating through all
the days of the week like that so I will
say that that is a very straightforward
approach and some assistants do use that
implementation however in practice it's
a lot less conversational than you might
think so how about you try asking me
what's the weather like this week and
then I'll use your algorithm to generate
a response all right sounds good we'll
call this the Adjustment Assistance set
perfect okay Justin what's the weather
like next week hi you Fang Sunday it'll
be 66 degrees and partly cloudy Monday
it'll be 63 degrees and cloudy Tuesday
it will be 66 degrees and partly cloudy
Wednesday it'll be 68 degrees in cloudy
oh boy okay yeah that's too long and
just too robotic yeah let's let's call
it let's call it that yeah you've been
saying it for me you felt a little
strange
yeah so clearly generating natural
language from structured data is
non-trivial how would you actually go
about using a computer system to answer
the users question then
well first you know I would want to
think about how it answered as a human
so you know as a human I would hope that
I'd be a little more contextually aware
and I would realize that there's
actually a lot of repetitive information
in the data so I'd probably try to
summarize it something like it'll be
cloudy until Thursday with showers the
rest of the week temperatures range from
the high 40s to the mid 60s hey you
might want to consider a career as a
weather forecaster if you know the
research thing doesn't work out yeah
maybe all right so we've done a little
bit of an overview of natural language
generation about what makes conversation
natural and we even gave kind of a
admittedly silly example of leveraging
this structured data to select content
for a natural language response yeah
and we've also included some links with
more info in the video that's right now
we have all right so then getting back
to the topic at hand how how does
machine learning then get involved well
that's the ultimate question that our
team is trying to answer without machine
learning everything that we've talked
about so far from parsing the data to
figure out what to say to actually
figure out how to say it
it had you have to do this with writing
lots of rules and rules are great
they're very stable they're very
predictable but they're usually very
specific and they require a lot of
engineering and because of that it's not
really scalable to new inputs and
outputs for example if we wanted to talk
about finance
instead of weather or if we wanted to
support an entire new language
altogether sure it would require writing
a whole new set of rules yeah and it
sounds like that would be way harder to
maintain as well keeping all those rules
lined up as things change and it would
also be hard to replicate that
creativity and spontaneity that comes
with human conversation right so that's
exactly one of the motivations of our
research our hope is that by giving the
model examples of data and the language
it needs to generate we can let the
model form its own rules about what to
do and not only does this save us from
having to write these rules ourselves by
hand but it also gives the computer more
free rein to be creative in its own way
so showing many examples to answer
questions you might say so that you can
write fewer rules I mean that's kind of
the crux of machine learning as a whole
that's wonderful exactly yeah and and so
what kind of machine learning
architectures then are you guys
exploring to try to protect this problem
well so far we've seen really promising
results with recurrent neural networks
but that's just one kind of neural
architecture that we're exploring okay
recurrent neural networks so on our
previous episode we looked at deep
neural networks on the show and that had
neurons connected in layers resulting in
something kind of lattice structure
right and for our viewers can you
explain what it means to have a
recurrent neural network yeah so you can
kind of think of a recurrent neural
network as a deep neural network but
just wrapped in a for loop and the
network is recurrent because the outputs
of the network feed back into itself and
instead of this kind of one-shot you
know input/output the model can kind of
make decisions over several time steps
okay awesome that's a really great way
that I kind of conceptualize it really
love that and we've also included some
links about recurrent neural networks
down below and if you have more
questions about this kind of network
structure feel free to leave them below
in the comments and we'll try to get to
them for now we'll talk about why
recurrent neural networks will be useful
for doing natural language generation
right so it's important to keep in mind
that language just in general is
extremely sequential sure yeah for
example the cat sat on the mat is a very
different sentence from cats at than
that on yeah order matters definitely so
are nuns are especially good at
remembering what it kind of saw earlier
because it enforces a sequential policy
over the data the inputs are decided in
a very ordered manner and instead of in
these kind of large conglomerates okay
so I guess it's both amazing and not
entirely surprising that recurrent
neural Nets would be useful for natural
language problems it sounds like so as
humans we rely a lot on what we
previously said to figure out what we'll
say next exactly well let's talk a bit
more than on how you're using these
recurrent neural nets to generate this
language so one kind of fun variation
when it comes to recurrent neural nets
is that since the output is generated
one step at a time you can kind of
choose the granularity of your output so
some models can choose coarser outputs
like entire word phrases
just words in general and then this goes
all the way down to models that outputs
like bytes a single bytes at a time by
the time and for us the we've been using
outputs at the character level okay so
be like spelling out the words really
right okay and this kind of model is
called ik is a character based RNN and
you can find out more information in the
links below so when we first talked
about having you on the show you showed
me this interesting graph here right
I would love to understand a little
better what is it showing us exactly so
this is a small visualization of our
recent research each row here represents
different pieces of our structured data
the shading of the squares indicates how
much the model actually cares about that
piece of structured data and lastly each
column represents a single step in our
model so as we travel across the columns
you can see how the model has learned to
pay attention to the structure data at
different time steps
okay so we're kind of traveling left to
right character by character for each
column and so the lit portions the
lighter parts are parts that the model
is paying attention to right exactly
okay and then on this model over here
for example it means the model is paying
attention to this bit to decide what
character it out but it's not saying
that that's the character we'll say
it'll just that's just the data it's
looking at right exactly so it's gonna
look at that particular piece of data to
try to think about what - what character
town exactly and then one really cool
result is this diagonal line in headed
oh about that it's kind of formulaic and
it almost looks like you guys added that
in afterwards - yeah it'd make it make
for something interesting it's like hard
coded yeah so those particular pieces of
data are basically the characters for a
specific location and what that diagonal
line is showing us is that when the
model has reached the part of the
sentence where it wants to spell out the
specific location is learn to read that
from the data character by character wow
that is that is awesome and no one
taught the model to do that they were
just able to learn how to do that just
by looking at examples exactly
that's the magic ncredible that's that's
super outstanding yeah
so um the diagonal line is pretty cool
but if you dive into our data there's
actually a lot of other intriguing ways
that the model kind of learns by itself
how to reference the data to decide what
character to output so you know that
said there's still a ton to explore but
I'm super excited to see what you know
where we come up with in the future and
how far we can push our research this
looks super cool Justin and I am really
excited to hear about what your team
comes up with next
maybe maybe you'll write a research
paper using one of these networks
interview yeah that sounds pretty fun
yeah Justin I want to thank you so much
for coming into the studio today and
teaching our viewers about natural
language generation looking forward to
catching up again in a minute I'm gonna
wrap up here yeah okay sounds good it
was my pleasure all right well I hope
you enjoyed this episode of AI
adventures I certainly did in our
conversation we talked about using
machine learning for natural language
generation and its role in
conversational user interfaces I had a
blast chatting with Justin and if you
like this format please let us know in
the comments below and for more
information and details about everything
that we talked about we've included tons
of links in the description and be sure
to subscribe to the channel to catch
future episodes and maybe some more
interviews as they come out